okay what up guys what up what up
we are working with some new
[Music]
oh wait hold on
working with some new equipment i reset
up my stream
in a different part of my apartment
so let me know if the sound and video is
okay
but let's
let's get it okay so today
i am reacting to amber heard
i have never seen this interview
so
should i put my mic here
you guys are gonna have to work with me
okay i just want to make sure we're live
let's see let's see let's see let's see
okay we are live okay
the sound is good okay
so nbc today the amber heard interview
everyone's been reacting to this but me
and i just feel a little bit left out so
i want to see what i'm missing out on so
if you guys don't know what happened
with amber heard um
she
is a crazy hell
i mean lady and
basically
she got in trouble for a dif i feel like
i don't even have to re-explain this
because you guys know what happened but
i will so she got in trouble for
defaming johnny depp she ruined this
man's career said he abused her
and the audacity of this woman she was
abusing him
gaslighting that's like the definition
of gaslighting
how do you know it's bad if you haven't
seen it i haven't seen the full thing
okay i've seen little clips
you guys always you're always on my ass
okay
can you hear me okay i want to put the
mic here but i don't know if that's too
far
no we don't want that in the shot okay
so we're gonna we're gonna watch it
more than a week since the verdict
as you sit here with me now
has it sunk in
how could it
surreal
and
difficult
in part yes
um this has been
a long time coming do you stand by
your testimony and your accusations
against johnny depp about abuse of
course to my dying day will stand by
every word of my testimony
the real life drama
so can you take her back to court
like ma'am did you not learn your lesson
you just were found guilty
of defamation
and now you're doing it again
not even a week after the interview
ended
the audacity
what the
mama of the defamation case between
amber heard and her ex-husband johnny
depp captivated millions of people
around the world
what did you guys say in her prime was
she a 10
would you put amber her to 10
okay
johnny you hit me
this is so cringe
with clips spreading across social media
like wildfire
i think vast majority of this trial was
played out on social media i think that
this trial
is an example of that gone
[Music]
haywire gone amok and the jury is not
immune to that you think the jury saw it
how could they not i think even the most
well-intentioned juror
it would have been impossible to avoid
this
people online and crowds outside the
courthouse made it clear where they
stood
every single day i passed
for
three four sometimes six blocks city
blocks lined with people oh no is that
the consequences of my own actions
the consequences of my own
decisions the audacity you're lucky
you're not locked up ma'am
the audacity
holding signs
saying burn the witch
death to
amber after three and a half weeks i
took the stand
and saw just a courtroom packed
full
of captain jack sparrow fans
who were vocal energized can you put
into words
how
that
felt this was the most humiliating and
horrible thing i've ever been through i
have never felt
more
removed from my own humanity
i
i've felt less than human
let's go back to the day of the verdict
were you feeling confident
she can't she doesn't say yes you can't
after the number your lawyers did on you
oh no
i mean don't get me wrong i don't know
if they could have saved her
but i feel like i could have defended
her better than her lawyers did oh my
god that's a great question
i wish i could say yes to that
i want to say yes to you but it
would wouldn't be true
even if you think
that i'm lying you still couldn't tell
me
look me in the eye and tell me that you
think on social media there's been a
fair representation do you find that mr
depp has proven all the elements of i
don't know amber you got a pretty fair
representation for the first five years
you got a pretty good representation the
first five years you got you got a whole
op-ed
to explain your story
it's like the audacity of this woman
defamation
answer yes
after the six-week trial the jury found
her defamed depp in a 2018 washington i
hate myself
throughout this whole clip i keep
thinking about how pretty she is
even
even though she's insane i'm like
goddamn she has nice eyes that's what
okay in post op-ed in which she wrote
she was a public figure representing
domestic abuse she never mentioned her
ex-husband by name
depp denied the abuse allegations in
court heard won just one of three claims
in her countersuit against her
ex-husband
that verdict came less than two years
after a judge ruled against stepp in a
similar case in the u.k in which he sued
a british newspaper that called him a
wife beater
there was another trial
handled in with the same dealt with the
same substantive issues that had even
more evidence in in fact mine
my evidence was largely kept out really
important pieces of evidence kept out
done differently handled differently
by a judge instead of a jury some
evidence is admissible in a uk court
that is not admissible in a u.s court do
you think that maybe he just had better
lawyers i will say his his lawyers did a
certainly a better job of distracting
the jury from the real issues for some
people
ma'am you chopped off his finger
that's what i would say if i was
interviewing her i'd be like
did did you did you not chop off his
finger with a bottle
do you think i'm stupid amber like the
audacity
they just would frankly disgusted by the
whole thing and don't have much sympathy
for either one of you
can you understand that
absolutely
i would not blame the average person for
looking at this and how it's been
covered
and not think that it is
hollywood brats that they're at their
worst
but
what people don't understand is it's
it's actually
so much bigger than that
this is uh
this is not only about
our first amendment right to speak but
here's the thing about the first
amendment the first amendment protects
free speech
it doesn't protect lies that amount to
defamation and that was the issue in the
case yes exactly you can't go into the
free speech does not protect you if you
you know go into a crowded theater and
you scream fire we get the concept of
free speech from the greeks my
understanding of what that means is not
just the freedom to speak
it's a freedom to speak truth to power
you just said nothing that's what i
would respond with i'd be like amber
i don't why are you bringing the greeks
into this
now for it look at me amber look at me
look into my eyes
did you or did you not chop off this
man's finger
and [ __ ] on his bed
i've said all i needed to say
the truth is the word yes that was the
issue and that's all i spoke
and i spoke it to power and i paid the
price
in the closing arguments the depth
lawyer said
called your testimony the performance of
a lifetime and said you were acting
what do you say to that
bruh she's going to be such a [ __ ] actor
because
not great not a great performance amber
says
the lawyer
for the man who convinced the world he
had scissors for fingers
i'm the performer i had listened to
weeks of testimony
insinuating that or saying quite
directly that
you know i'm a terrible actress
so i i'm i'm a bit confused how i could
be both the depth team argued that you
were the abuser that you instigated
physical violence did you
i never had to instigate it i responded
to it when you're living in violence and
it becomes
becomes normal as i testified to
you have to adapt you say you were
responding but there is evidence there
are tapes
in which you acknowledge hitting there
are tapes in which you say i started the
fight
i know much has been made of of these
audio tapes they were first leaked
online after being
edited what you would hear in those
clips are not evidence of what was
happening it was evidence of a
negotiation
of how to talk about that with
your abuser but i am looking at it
oh she broke out the transcripts
yes i was like i would have played it
right then and there a transcript that
says he says you start physical fights
and you say i did start a physical fight
i can't promise you i won't get physical
again
i mean this is in black and white i
understand context
but you're testifying and you're just
telling me today i never started a
physical fight and here you are on tape
saying you did as i testified on the
stand about this is that when your life
is at risk
not only will you take the blame for
things that you shouldn't take the blame
for but when you're in an abusive
dynamic psychologically
emotionally and physically you don't
have the resources that say you or i do
with the luxury of saying hey this is
black and white because it's anything
but when you're living in it but then
there are other times there's another
tape where you're taunting him and
saying oh tell the world johnny depp i a
man i'm a victim of domestic violence 20
second clips or the transcripts of them
are not representative of
even the two hours or the three hours
that those clips are excerpt from okay
look at
amber i empathize
okay
i really do
i mean i've been clipped and taken out
of context before
and a lot of times you're right
they'll take a small clip and they won't
talk about the three-hour livestream i
did
but i'll tell you what i didn't do
[ __ ] in a guy's bed
chop his finger off
bro
okay let's let's continue
could your side have just put the whole
three hours in then i'm not a lawyer as
i testified to i was
talking in those recordings as a person
an extreme amount of emotional
psychological and physical distress
he said it doesn't never
hit you
he never is that a lie yes it is
what about the witnesses who said they
have seen you
instigate physical violence i've seen
firsthand how people will file rank
and support the person they depend on
did they all come in and lie in court
i am not here to call any of
these witnesses
any names i'm here to just kind of talk
about it from
what it felt like for me as a person who
not not what it felt like for you
i wish i could have interviewed her send
her to me
okay
it shouldn't be what it felt like for
you it should be what happened
boo hoo poor me poor me like shut up
he's out there when i asked his lawyers
why do you think you won and the answer
i got was
because she never took responsibility
for anything
she did in the marriage
i
did do and say horrible
regrettable things name them
name them right now throughout my
relationship
i behaved in horrible
almost unrecognizable to myself ways
there's so much i have so much regret i
freely and openly and voluntarily
talked about what i did i talked about
the horrible language i talked about
being pushed to the extent where i
didn't even know the difference between
you know
right and wrong i
will always
continue to
feel like i was a part of this like i
was the other half of this relationship
because i was
and it was ugly
yeah
i got you see the crazy eyes oh i can
see it you ever like sometimes women we
just talk to talk
and i know what you're thinking
i do this all the time on my show
but but i swear to god sometimes as
women
we just talk to like say things with no
point at all
yeah okay
and could be very beautiful
you chopped his finger off what was
beautiful about this relationship very
very toxic
we were awful to each other
you know i made a lot of
a lot of mistakes
like pooping in his bed
sorry i'm gonna keep bringing this up a
lot of mistakes
but i've always told the truth
herd's lawyers say they plan to appeal
that verdict and as for the notion from
her that there was evidence allowed in
that uk trial that could have
potentially made a difference last week
depp's attorney said here on today that
the evidence presented in the latest
trial far exceeded the uk one two
different processes and they believe the
jury got it right
we have a lot more of our conversation
to share with you tomorrow morning on
today including okay wait i have part
two i have it pulled
up what the
was that part two
oh no okay
gotta start it there
okay
a text message where johnny promises
total global humiliation for you
do you feel like that came true
oh did i do this backwards
did i do these backwards was i trippin
let me see in the chat
um
this is
part one isn't this what i just watched
let me just make sure
it's been about more than a week oh no
okay okay
okay we're good we're good here we go
i know he promised it
i testified to this
i'm not
a good victim i get it i'm not a likable
victim i'm not a perfect victim
but
i
when i test i'm not a victim
you could just say that
okay but i asked the jury to just see me
as human and hear
his own words
which is a promise to do this it feels
as though he has
amber heard reflecting on the ripple
effects of her tumultuous trial with
johnny depp
having been found live yeah amber heard
smasher pass in the chat smash or pass
are you nervous
as we are here today about
what you can say now
of course
i took for granted
what i assumed was my right to speak
do you feel like you could be sued again
by him for defamation you should be sued
again after this interview god damn i'm
scared
that
no matter what i do
no matter what i say or how i say it
um every step that i take
will present another opportunity
for
this sort of uh silencing
which is what i guess the defamation
lawsuit is meant to do it's meant to
take your voice okay let's say amber is
correct and
okay
i don't for a second believe this i'm
sorry but as a girl if you're getting
your ass b and you start hitting him
back
i don't believe that's what happened but
let's let's go with this train for a
second if you're getting your ass beat
and you're heading back you're in a
mutually abusive relationship so if
you're going gonna go online and say oh
i'm a victim i'm a victim
i you gotta present all the information
if you're if it's a mutually abusive
relationship
i would still say that's defamation of
character but you know
i don't
i don't think that's what happened right
i'm team johnny you know that we're team
johnny over here but i'm just saying
okay
but amber is still speaking just days
after a jury stunned many and found the
actress defamed depp in an op-ed where
she said she was a public figure
representing domestic abuse
the piece which never mentioned depp by
name was published two years after the
couple announced they had settled their
divorce
life had seemingly moved on and you
decide to write an op-ed
why did you do that because op-ed wasn't
about
my relationship with johnny but it
alluded to him
it was unmistakable
you know what the op-ed was about was um
you know me loaning my voice to bigger
cultural conversation that we were
having at the time did you worry gosh
i'd love to be a person weighing in on
these cultures wow
did you want to mention how you [ __ ] in
his bed in that op-ed when he lost his
pirates of the caribbean movie
that's crazy
silence crickets
shoes but that's gonna stir this all up
again i obviously knew it was important
for me not to make it
about him
or to
do anything like defame him i had
lawyers teams of lawyers
review
all the drafts of this when you wrote
this op-ed it was the height of me too
legions of powerful men
being
cancelled losing their jobs
um
there are way too many of you in the
chat that still would say smash
there are way too many of you in the
chat that are still saying smash
look at usually i say the audacity of
these women and i still believe that the
audacity of this woman
but the audacity of you guys you trying
to die you trying to lose your finger is
it worth it
for a female
okay i'm gonna continue did you want
that to happen to johnny depp
of course not
of course not it wasn't about him
but the op-ed and the abuse alleged was
at the heart of the six-week trial just
pulls his arm back with the phone and
throws it at my face
hit me right in my it felt like my eye
heard testified that the final straw
came after a violent fight in may 2016.
six days later she filed for a
restraining order cameras capturing her
as she left the courthouse
but depp's lawyers convinced the jury
heard was lying about the abuse police
who responded to the 2016 incident
testified during the trial that they
didn't see any injuries and that hurd
declined to file charges this was a hoax
is according to his team
why didn't i cooperate with the police
as i've testified before and i will
stand by until my dying day i didn't
want to cooperate with him i didn't want
this to be out i didn't want this okay
now this is sometimes ladies let's just
have a talk
between me and you ladies
our actions
don't match what we're saying so if you
said i didn't want the police to get
involved okay
i didn't want this to be out there and
then let me just
follow that up with then you write an
op-ed
some people kind of look at you funny
like what what's going on with this you
know what i mean
to be known
i didn't
want to cooperate with them because i
didn't want this to be i didn't want to
get him in trouble if it was a host i
could have done that but five days later
you went to court and it came out five
days later i made the decision
to stand up for myself and protect
myself you can't get a restraining order
in private which of course i didn't
understand the night when the cops were
called
an employee of tmz testified at court
and said that tmz was tipped off about
when you were going to be going to the
courthouse and on what side of your face
bruises would be a parent
did you tip off tmz i was going to say
he certainly didn't get tipped off by me
or anyone in my mind
why would they no you ask no one to why
would they
because you're crazy amber
this is why you can't stick your dick in
crazy
look at
i can't believe how many of you said yes
in the chat i'm
baffled
baffled
as i testified to before
had nothing to do with me there are
different incidents that you testified
to and the depth legal team would put up
pictures of you publicly
right after that or in the days
following and saying
that why are there no no bruises again
it's that thing if you have bruising if
you have injuries it's fake
if you don't have any then it's then you
weren't injured you had promised to
donate the seven million dollars of your
divorce settlement to charity it was
revealed at trial that
you haven't done so yet however they
played a tape where you stayed on the
air that you have donated it do you
think that raised questions as to your
credibility with the jury
i mean the audacity
that is a lot of money i don't i don't
know why she pledged that like if that
was me
i would just be like look
yeah i'm keeping this i'm keeping it
okay i made a pledge
and
that pledge
is made over time by its nature and you
say i donated
you know that everybody thinks that
you've donated it not that you've
pledged it so
for the jurors sitting there
do you think they felt like that was you
getting caught in a lie
i i don't know because so much of the
i feel like so much
of the trial was meant to
cast aspersions on who i am as a human
my credibility to call me a liar and in
every way you can and that was the trial
it was a credibility contest
okay she's finally getting sassy
she's finally getting sassy i've been
she's been a little too nice for me in
this interview and that was it this is
another one of the examples where if you
pull back and you think about it i
shouldn't have to
donated it in an effort to be believed i
shouldn't have had to earmark the
entirety of that in order to have you
shouldn't have but once you said you did
right which is where thank you for the
super chats guys i see one whatever
happens after you guys smash a woman
like this is on you don't complain about
how man
how bad men have it after she ruins you
look it that's what i'm saying i'm like
guys
way too many of you put smash crazy
makes the girls even hotter why
what is wrong with you
okay well
look
i don't know okay thank you for the
super chats they go towards i want to
get ish the camera when we live stream
beyond a cd looks like some money
intended to go heard says she still
plans to honor that pledge how do you
see your future now
i get to be a mom like
full-time you know where i'm not having
to juggle
calls
you certainly won't be juggling your
acting career i'll say that much
you certainly are gonna have a lot of
free time amber
with lawyers one day you may
want to tell your daughter about this or
have to tell your daughter
about everything that you've gone
through what would you
want to say
i think
no matter what
i'd pledge the tip of my finger for some
of that whenever whether i donate it is
another story amber attorney thank you
for the five dollar super chat again
goes towards new cameras okay sorry
i'm really trying to get a lot of
donations before the end of the month
because then at the end of next month i
can buy the cameras it'll be an exciting
day okay will mean something
i did the right thing
i
did everything i could
to stand up for myself and the truth
heard and depp's volatile relationship
lasted just four years depp confirming
his engagement to me on today in 2014.
congratulations thank you are you
excited yeah
oh my god was johnny depp hot i didn't
even notice in pirates of the crew he's
he's gone downhill a little bit since
but oh my goodness
the she's a wonderful girl and she's uh
she's sharp as attacks you know
wonderful you know uh
southern belle and
sweet as can be and
very good for me you know
on the first day of the trial you
issued a statement and part of the
statement said i still have love for
johnny
yes is that still true yes
after everything absolutely
absolutely yeah i [ __ ] in the people i
love's bed too
that's crazy i do the same thing don't
clip that
don't clip me
guys so you guys will take me out of
context
anyways
but yeah sarcastic clearly
i love him
i loved him with all my heart
and i tried the best i could to make a
deeply broken relationship work
and
i couldn't
i
have no bad feelings or ill will towards
him at all
i think he has some ill will towards you
i'm not gonna lie
okay
i
i know that might
be hard to understand it might be really
easy to understand if you've just never
loved anyone it should be easy
i have no words
depp's attorneys have said they do not
see the verdict in this case as a
setback to victims of domestic violence
coming forward heard's legal team has
said they do plan to appeal this summer
quick note we will have more of our
conversation with amber heard during a
special edition of dateline including
evidence she says should have been
included in the trial that would have
bolstered her case you can stream part
of it a sneak preview tomorrow on wait
there's another part i thought it was
just two parts
let me know in the chat where do i find
part three um
oh another five dollar super chat you
said smash not marry but guys why would
you that's so risky
that's like me saying i'd sleep with the
felon
i know it's just for now but like
bro
okay amber
oh part three no this is
okay wait let's what there's a text
message let's find this nbc
wait she say i believe amber
okay
no i don't see part three
is there a part three hold on i'm
checking the comments
um
on their app or website
why not sleep with a felon are you
i just i shouldn't be having these
discussions on youtube
what you're suggesting is that we all
stay celibate that's a little dramatic
guys
there are some nice girls out there
there are some nice girls if you can't
get them i'm sorry i don't know what to
tell you but i
i know some girls that will not chop
your finger off okay i do
um marcus four four whatever um i beat
when i first saw heard
i thought one of my favorite prawn stars
haley reed started acting
okay i don't
oh my goodness okay
um
well
i guess this is just we'll do one and
two because i don't see this
okay
well i'm gonna end this live because i
don't see part three
um
anyways stop with the clown of me okay
don't stick your dick in crazy
um
the audacity of this woman
i love you guys you're my favorites